OF. GOOD MORNING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MAY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. USUALLY
ADVISE AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDING AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDED THIS HEARING ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES. ATTENDEES MUST OFFER
FRIEND FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT
INDIVIDUALS REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HERE WALDRON. BENNETT
FLORA FONG. GIPSON EUROPE HERE
LADY MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS STONE
THE ABUJA FORMS. WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
- MADAM VICE CHAIR- I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST REMOVING
THE- THE ITEMS NINE AND TEN FROM
CONSENT AND ASKED THAT WE VOTE
ON THEM SEPARATELY FROM THE
OTHERS FORGET THAT WILL BE THE
ORDER BUSINESS- IS OUR MOST OF
THE REMAINDER OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA BOOK BY MISTER GIPSON
SECONDED BY MR MATHIS AMER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE WALDRON
WALDRON AYE BENNETT. THEN I A
FLORA FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON HI LEE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE STONE BE A GOOD ONE- SO- ARE
WE STILL IN KALRA YEAH WE DON'T
BELIEVE THOSE ON CALL OTHERS ARE
MOTION ITEM NINE YEARS HE CLAWS
REQUEST FOR AB TWENTY NINETY
ONE. OF MOVE BY MR GIPSON SECOND
BRIBE. MR MAT L. SIX. SEVEN A
SEMI MR MATTIS- ALL RIGHTS WE
HAVE THE ROLE ON THEIR. COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE WALDRON WALDRON-
BENNETT BENNETT I FLORA FONG
FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON HIGHLY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE STONE THE
APPROVED LAW. OKAY WILL WE'VE
GOT A LIVE THAT ON CALL- IS OUR
MOTION ITEM TEN YEARS HE CLAWS
MOVERS ARE GAPS GIPSON SECONDED
BY. MISTER BENNETT OF. SO WHAT
CHANGED ON NINE AND NOW FORGET.
IT'S SUCH A OR THINKING OF- AND-
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
GIPSON SECOND BY MR BEEN ON ITEM
TEN- CICLOS REQUEST FOR AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX. MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE WALDRON
WALDRON- BENNETT SENATE HI FLORA
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON HI
LEE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS NO. STONE THE
VALLAPUDUA. OKAY WE WILL LEAVE
THOSE TWO ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- WE'LL TURN NOW TO. I
HAVE TWO BILLS TO PRESENT THIS
MORNING. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ITEMS NUMBER ELEVEN AND TWELVE
AB TWENTY TWO OH NINE AND AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY. PLEASE CHECK IN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. WITH THE L.
EXACTLY- I WILL PRESENT THEM IN
TURN I WANT TO SAY TO JUST BY
WAY OF OPENING THAT AS A PART OF
OUR RESPONSE WAS AS THE JOINT
RULES CHAIR OF THE SENATE'S
PROJECT ACTUALLY STARTED WITH
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER AND STUDY
SHE CONDUCTED THE BUILDING IT'S
BEEN KICKING ALL KICKING ALONG
NOW THEREFORE UNDER FIVE JOINT
RULES CHAIRS OF WOMAN THE ONLY
THE LATEST. IS BEEN MY PRACTICE
TO TRY TO ON BEHALF INSTITUTION
LOOK WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
BE READY I DON'T THINK THE
PROJECT LOOKS GOOD TO MARCH FROM
CHAOS TO CHAOS IN THESE BILLS
ARE SIMPLY PROVIDE VEHICLES IF
IN THE COURSE THE NEEDS YEAR WE
DETERMINED THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING OUGHT TO BE DONE AND-
SO AB TWENTY TWO OH NINE- THE-
THIS BILL. STATE CAPITOL
BUILDING ANNEX ACTIVE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AUTHORIZES JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE TO PURSUE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW ANNEX
BUILDING. OR THE RESTORATION
REHABILITATION RENOVATION OR
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE EXISTING
STATE CAPITOL BUILDING ANNEX. IN
FURTHERANCE OF THE ACTION
PLANTATION THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE BEGAN CAPITAL HAS
PROJECT. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
PROVIDE CITY KAPLAN IS PROJECT
MAY BE PURSUED IN PHASES. AND
AUTHORIZES ANY RELATED OR
NECESSARY DE CONSTRUCTION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK. REQUIRED IN
FURTHERANCE OF THE PROJECT
CURRENT LAW ALREADY AUTHORIZES
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE TO PURSUE
ANY OTHER ANCILLARY
IMPROVEMENTS. TO EFFECTUATE THE
PURPOSES OF THE ACT- EXISTING
GOVERNMENT CODE NINETY ONE
TWELVE A MAKES CLEAR
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING ANNEX IS
EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZED. ALONG WITH
A VISITORS CENTER AND RELOCATED
UNDERGROUND PARKING FACILITY.
THESE ARE ENUMERATED EXAMPLES IN
SECTION NINETY ONE TWELVE A ONE
OF EXISTING ALL. AB TWENTY TWO
OH NINE AYE THANK YOU FOR THAT
MOTION SIMPLY CLARIFIES CURRENT
LAW PROVIDED BY PROVIDING THE
LIST OF ENUMERATED EXAMPLES
INSTRUCTION NINETY ONE TWELVE A
ONE. THAT CONSISTS WITH THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEES EXISTING
AUTHORITY TO PURSUE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A STATE CAPITOL
BILLION ANNEX. AND ANY OTHER
ANSWER IMPROVEMENTS ANY RELATED
FURNACE ARE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
ALSO AUTHORIZED AND I. THAT'S AB
TWENTY TWO OH NINE AND I REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR COOLEY
. WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
APPLYING. I DO NOT ANTICIPATE
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU WE CAN NOW TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY I COME FORWARD
AMPLE PHYSICAL. YEAH. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. TWO MINUTES. MY
NAME IS SANDRA HEDSTROM WHEN
I'VE BEEN IN THIS BUILDING TWO
HUNDRED TIMES. I HAVE BEEN
LABELED A TERRORIST. I WAS IN
THIS BUILDING WHEN SEVEN.
PARENTS WERE ARRESTED IN
SEPTEMBER OF NINETEEN I HAD COME
TO BE A FLY ON THE WALL AND
INSTEAD I AM STILL HERE STILL
COMING BACK I THINK IT SAYS IN
THE PROBERBS LIKE A DOG TO THE
VOMIT. HI CALIFORNIANS CAN'T
FEED THEMSELVES. THEY ARE BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BY PHARMA
FASCIST BILLS. PEOPLE ARE
FLEEING. THEY CAN'T FILL THEIR
GAS TANKS. AND YOUR GOING TO
BUILD YOURSELVES A GLASS PALACE
TO YOUR OWN POWER. YOU SPENT
WHAT FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE SWING
SPACE A PLACE YOU DON'T EVEN LET
ME GO AT THIS POINT. BECAUSE OF
YOUR TIERNEY. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS. DO WE WANT TO TALK
ECONOMICS WE CAN TALK ABOUT
COMMUNISM THE GOVERNMENT OWNS
ALL MEANS OF PRODUCTION WE CAN
TALK ABOUT FASCISM. THAT
INDUSTRY OWNS GOVERNMENT BUT
WHEN YOU FORCE MEDICAL
INJECTIONS INTO PEOPLE AGAINST
THEIR WISHES TIERNEY IS
INARGUABLE. AND NOW YOU WANT A
GLASS PALACE A SHRINE TO YOUR
OWN POWER. I'M A DISPLACED
PERSON FROM A FIRE. THE LAST
TIME I SAW YOU IN HERE CAN. IN
THIS ROOM I TALKED TO YOU YOU
KNOW MY CHILDREN YOU KNOW THEM
BY NAME. CALIFORNIANS ARE
SUFFERING BUT YOU NEED A GLASS
PALACE WE DON'T NEED TO GO INTO
ECONOMIC SYSTEMS IF ANY OF YOU
HAVE ANY MORALITY LEFT IN YOUR
BODIES YOU KNOW THIS PROJECT IS
WRONG. THANK YOU ANY OTHER CALL
YES I'M RACHEL GATES FROM ORANGE
COUNTY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
PERSONALLY MY LEAD TO SPEAKERS
AT LIKE A OKAY I'M I'M A
PRESCHOOL TEACHER THAT. IT WAS
DRIVEN OUT BY THE STATE BECAUSE
I CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE OR BUY
GROCERIES AND SO. I'M A
CALIFORNIA REFUGEE AND I'M ONE
OF I CAN'T COUNT TENS OF
THOUSANDS AND- VERY DISAPPOINTED
BY MY LIFELONG PARTY THAT I
THOUGHT STOOD FOR MY BODY MY
CHOICE AND I ENDED UP WITH.
FIGHTING FOR MANDATES AND SO.
IT'S BEEN A ROUGH ROAD I DIDN'T
WANT TO LEAVE CALIFORNIA I WAS
BORN HERE BUT- ACTUALLY CAME
BACK WITH THE PEOPLE'S CONVOY
THAT WANTED TO STAND UP AND
FIGHT BACK WITH. WHICH IS IT IS
IT MY BODY MY CHOICE OR IS IT
TYRANNY AND- IT'S JUST VERY SAD
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS A
BEAUTIFUL STATE AND I JUST. I'M
FRUSTRATED AND I LOVE THE TREES
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR I GET
THAT SOMEBODY MIGHT WANT SOME
RENOVATIONS IN AN OLDER BUILDING
. MY QUESTION WOULD BE WHY THE
TREES HAVE TO GO AND- THEN AGAIN
HOW DOES HOW DO WE AS ACT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THIS MUCH
MONEY. JUST TO SPARE I MEAN IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU A WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE OTHER ANY
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. I REQUEST IT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE MR
COOLEY'S CLOSE THAT YOU'RE CLOSE
. OKAY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON AB TWENTY TWO R. NINE
TO PASS COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE BENNETT
BENNETT I FLORA FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON GIPSON HIGHLY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE STONE BE A GOOD ONE. MOTION
PASSES MOTION PASSES FOR A
MISTER COOLEY PLEASE BEGIN ON AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN. SECOND HAS
STATED THIS IS A VEHICLE OF
STATE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD WAS
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
NINETEEN FORTY SIX TO OVERSEE
FISCAL MATTERS OF SOCIAL WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION PROJECT FOR
STATE AGENCIES. AND TO SELECT
THE REQUIRED REAL PROPERTY FOR
STATE FACILITIES AND PROGRAMS IT
IS ALSO ALSO THE ISSUER OF LEASE
REVENUE BONDS WHICH ARE A FORM
OF LONG TERM FINANCING USED TO
PAY FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS. AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX BACK IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF SIGNED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN AUTHORIZES STATE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD ISSUE LEASE
REVENUE BONDS OR NOTES PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE ACQUISITION
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION OF A
STATE CAPITOL BUILDING ANNEX IN
ANY ANCILLARY IMPROVEMENTS TO
AFFECT WITH KAPLAN'S PROJECT.
THIS BILL MAKES CLEAR THAT THE
EXTENT RELIED UPON THE BOND
AUTHORITY EXTENDS WALL COST
STRUCTURE WITH RELATED OR NESTOR
WERE FOR THE PROJECT AUTHORIZED
BY GOVERNMENT COULD ANYONE
TWELVE INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES
PROVIDE BIOLOGIC COUNCILS A
VEHICLE. ON HAND OF I WILL
SIMPLY NOTE THAT AS INTEREST
RATES RISE THERE IS A QUESTION
OF WHETHER THAT A USEFUL LEASE
REVENUE BONDS IN THE PROJECT IS
A GOOD COURSE OF ACTION FOR
TAXPAYERS BUT I REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU TO HAVE WITH AND
- NO WITNESSES. NONE SUPPORT OF
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RACHEL GATES ORANGE COUNTY-
HONESTLY. I ACTUALLY DON'T EVEN
HAVE WORDS- I AM THOUGHT THAT
THANK YOU. OKAY THE RIGHT. ALL
THIS SOMEONE TRYING. I GET TWO
MINUTES IS THAT RIGHT YES.
WHAT'S FUNNY BECAUSE THERE'S
SOMETHING I WANNA READ. FROM ONE
OF THE- ACTIVIST FRIENDS OF MINE
WHO WAS ARRESTED. BECAUSE HE WAS
STANDING UP FOR THE RIGHT TO NOT
HAVE THE GOVERNMENT FORCED
MEDICAL INJECTIONS INTO HIS
VEINS OR HIS CHILDREN'S BRAINS
AND YET I CAN'T FIND IT BECAUSE
I'M A GOAT FARMER AND IT'S NOT
LIKE I LIKE ANY OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY. AND SO AS I SCROLL
FOR THIS THROUGH THIS THING I
COULD JUST TALK OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD BUT I COULD ALSO BE
QUIET I COULD JUST BE SILENT
BECAUSE WOULDN'T THAT BE A WAY
TO LIKE USE THE TIME. BECAUSE OF
ALL THE NOISE IN OUR CULTURE AND
YOU KNOW YOU LEGISLATORS. MAYBE
WHAT YOU NEED MAYBE WHAT I NEED
MAYBE WE ALL NEED TO JUST SIT
AND QUIET I DON'T KNOW MAYBE YOU
DON'T NEED ME TO READ SOMETHING
FROM THOMAS JEFFERSON MAYBE YOU
FROM- ONE OF OUR FOREFATHERS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT LIKE ANY OF YOU
SEEM TO BE PAYING ATTENTION TO
ANY OF THAT. ANYWAY BECAUSE IF
YOU WERE YOU WOULDN'T BE
BUILDING A GLASS PALACE TO YOUR
OWN POWER BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
HOW I SEE THIS. AND THE TRUTH IS
IF THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA KNEW
THAT THIS IS WHAT YOU WERE DOING
I'M CONVINCED THEY WOULD SEE IT
THAT WAY TOO. PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
YOU'RE DOING THIS THEY DON'T
EVEN KNOW THE BASICS OF
GOVERNMENT YOU'VE TAKEN CIVIC
SIDE OF THE SCHOOL THEY DON'T
EVEN KNOW THEY HAVE RIGHTS. THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT THEY
DON'T KNOW YOU'RE IN HERE
SPENDING OUR MONEY. AND IT'S
BEEN BY DESIGN AND WE KNOW THIS
AND THE PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF IT.
LIKE I SAID A MOMENT AGO THEY
CAN'T EVEN FILL THEIR GAS TANKS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
DISPLACED BY A FIRE AND YOU AND
YOUR BILL YESTERDAY LUCKY US
YOU'RE GONNA SPEND A BILLION
DOLLARS TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE
A ROAD OUT OF RURAL CALIFORNIA
WELL YOU SIT HERE. IN A PALACE
TO YOUR POWER. AND YOU TREAT US
LIKE PAT LITTLE KIDS ON THE HEAD
YEAH HEY WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
PEOPLE IN RURAL CALIFORNIA ROAD.
SO THAT THEY CAN DRIVE OUT IN
FLAMES. THAT **** IS HAPPENING
AND IT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE OF
YOU PEOPLE AND YOUR CRAPPIE
POLICIES. THE WATER. THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS U. TURN FROM ME
CAN IT'S BETTER THAN RUNNING YOU
HAVEN'T BUILT A DAM OR RESERVOIR
WITH EIGHT WATER BONDS WHAT ARE
YOU PEOPLE DOING. NOW YOU NEED A
GLASS PALACE WELL ENJOY IT
BECAUSE THE REST OF US WILL BE
IN FLORIDA. THANK YOU OF. ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. MR COOLEY PLEASE CALL
. I'M PLEASED TO BRING THIS BILL
TO AYE AYE WHAT DO WANT TO KNOW
FOR THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
RECORD THAT. WE ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS I DID WITHIN A FEW MONTHS
OF BECOMING GOING RULES. JOINT
WHEELCHAIR WHICH TOOK PLACE IN
JANUARY. OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WAS TO HAVE A WEBSITE CONCERNING
THE PROJECT HAS BEEN UP AND
RUNNING SINCE APRIL OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. SO WE HAVE CONSTANTLY
UPDATED THAT. IT'S BEEN. I DID
FEEL AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE COURTS
IT'S BEEN WIDELY COMMENT UPON.
BUT ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATURE
WE HAVE BEEN- MAINTAINING THAT
AND- PUT THE PROJECT IN THE
PUBLIC REALM- NOW MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS THAT'S BEEN UP AND RUNNING
AND REGULARLY UPDATED I REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND THE
SECOND MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETEEN TO PASS COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE WALDRON AYE WALDRON
AYE BENNETT. BENNETT I FLORA
FONG. FONG AYE GIPSON. GIPSON I
LEAVE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE STONE
STONE IV VALLAPUDUA. THE
VALLAPUDUA HI. MOTION PASSES.
MOTION PASSES. BUT WE DO HAVE
ITEMS ON CALL. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT VOTE ON THE CONSENT ITEMS
BILL REFERRALS AND RESOLUTIONS A
STONE. STONE IV APPROVED BY THE
VALLAPUDUA I. ON ITEMS NUMBER
NINE AND TEN THE URGENCY CLAUSE
REQUESTS STONE. STONE IV BUDDHA
THE BUDDHA. OF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THIS RULES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.